Hey, Conan O'Brien here,
and a very Happy St. Patrick's Day.
I hope you're all staying safe and washing your hands.
That's important.
Here is a quick tip on how you can keep your hands clean
in the old St. Pattie's Day spirit.
♪ Oh, Danny boy ♪
♪ The pipes, the pipes are calling ♪
♪ From glen to glen ♪
♪ And down the mountainside ♪
♪ The summer's gone and all the flowers are dying ♪
♪ Tis you, tis you must go ♪
♪ And I must bide ♪
♪ But come ye back when summer's in the meadow ♪
♪ Or when the valley's hushed and white with snow ♪
♪ 'Cause I'll be there ♪
♪ In sunshine or in shadow ♪
♪ Oh, Dan ♪
You know what?
It's too stupid.
It's just too stupid.
My apologies, Happy St. Patrick's Day.
Be safe, too stupid.